in today's rapidly evolving technology
landscape the role of devops has become
increasingly critical devops
professionals play a pivotal role in
Bridging the Gap between software
development and it operations enabling
organizations to deliver software faster
more reliably and with higher quality so
if you aspire to embark on a cardio in
devops this video on devops roadmap will
guide you through the roadmap to
becoming a successful devops
professional so let's get started but
before that do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn so the
first step is to acquire essential
skills well to thrive in the world of
devops several key skills are crucial
now the knowledge of continuous
integration and continuous development
is very important familiarize yourself
with tools like Jenkins gitlab and
Travis CI to automate build test and
deployment processes along with that you
should have efficiency in scripting and
automation you can learn scripting
languages such as python bash or
Powershell to automate routine tasks and
configuration and to Ace the skill next
is understanding of infrastructure as
code master tools like terraform or AWS
cloud formation to provision and manage
infrastructure resources
programmatically then comes the
knowledge of cloud computing acquire
knowledge of popular Cloud platforms
like AWS Azure or Google Cloud platform
to leverage cloud services and optimize
infrastructure following that you need
to learn about containerization and
orchestration familiarize yourself with
Docker for containerization and
kubernetes for container orchestration
to enable scalable and portable
applications once done with learning
about skills start exploring essential
tools and implementing your skills
devops professionals rely on a diverse
set of tools to streamline processes and
maximize efficiency First Tool is
Version Control System learn gate which
is widely used for source code
management collaboration and Version
Control then start exploring
configuration and management Master
tools like ansible puppet or shift
automate configuration management across
various systems following that learn
about collaboration and communication
familiarize yourself with collaboration
tools like jira Confluence and slack to
facilitate seamless communication and
project management learn about
infrastructure monitoring explore tools
such as nadius zabix or datadog to
monitor system health and performances
enabling proactive issue resolution once
done with these gain Proficiency in
tools like Docker and kubernetes to
deploy applications consistently across
multiple environments well here's a
surprise for you our Caltech
postgraduate program in devops will help
you learn these skills and tools in just
nine months this course is a
professional development option that
will Square your skills and Industry
standards a cutting-edge blended
learning combines live online devops
certification classes over interactive
Labs that will give you hands-on
experience on completion of this course
you will get a Catholic ctme post
graduate certificate along with hands-on
experience on Capstone projects like
dockerizing Jenkins pipeline deploy
angular application in Docker contain
and branching development mode
so to enroll now check out the link
mentioned in the description
now that we have covered skills and
tools let me tell you about the roles
and responsibilities
as a devops professional you will handle
first is collaboration you will be
responsible for facilitating effective
communication and collaboration between
development operations and other teams
Dennis continuous integration and
deployment you will be automating the
build test and deployment processes to
ensure efficient and Reliable Software
delivery you will also deal with
infrastructure management where you will
be designing provisioning and managing
infrastructure resources using Cloud
platforms and infrastructure as code
now if I talk about salary there's a
demand for skilled devops professional
is soaring translating into competitive
salaries
can vary based on factors such as
location experience and organization
size according to recent data the
average annual salary for a devops
engineer ranges between ninety thousand
two hundred fifty thousand dollars with
more experienced professionals earning
significantly higher salaries when the
journey to becoming a successful devops
professional requires a combination of
technical skills hands-on experience
with relevant tools by acquiring the
essential skills mastering the right
tools and embracing the diverse
responsibilities you can pave the way
well this was all about devops roadmap
if you like this video then please hit
the like button and share it with your
friends also if you have any questions
related to this video then please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here